Russian President Vladimir Putin calls
the attacks an act of aggression and is
seeking an emergency session of a United
stationed Security Council Jonathan
Vigliotti is in our London newsroom with
more on the reaction to the airstrikes
coming in from around the world Jonathan
good morning
Oriana good morning the operation capped
off nearly a week of debate between the
US UK and France and this morning all
nations involved were quick to support
the military action calling the strikes
restrained and precise it was a limited
targeted and effective strike with clear
boundaries that expressly sought to
avoid escalation speaking in London this
morning Prime Minister Theresa May said
the international community will not
stand by and tolerate the Syrian
government's use of chemical weapons we
cannot allow the use of chemical weapons
to become normalized either within Syria
on the streets of the UK or elsewhere
the US UK and France launched more than
100 missiles in a statement President
McCrone of France also noted that narrow
focus of the strike saying our response
has been limited to the Syrian regime's
facilities enabling the production and
deployment of chemical weapons Russia
who backs the Assad regime said the
Syrian military intercepted 71 of the
missiles and say there were no immediate
reports of casualties Moscow also called
into question the timing of the
operation which was launched on the same
day the organization for the prohibition
of chemical weapons was expected to
investigate the site in DOMA where
chemical weapons were allegedly used
this American aggression indicates that
the United States is not interested in
an objective investigation Iran's
supreme leader Ayatollah Ali Khamenei he
another ally of the Syrian government
went so far as to call president Trump
and his allies criminal in the US and
its ally said it would be criminal to do
nothing at all Frances foreign minister
said the strikes wiped out a large part
of Syria's chemical arsenal and said
more strikes were possible if chemical
weapons were used again
rina Jonathan Vigliotti in our London
newsroom thank you Jonathan